andré malraux andré malraux a été vos
grands amis oui on parlait beaucoup mais
on a l'impression en lisant vos mémoires
que vous n'avez pas eu une influence sur
lui et que lui n'a pas eu une influence
sur vous j'ai probablement vrai il faut
dire surtout que nous avons eu une
amitié entente authentique profondes
dans les années 30
nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la
première fois l'université de cologne où
il faisait une conférence je les ai
raccompagné son hôtel nous avons eu une
première conversation puis je les
retrouvais une décades de pontigny et à
l'époque même où il était un personnage
et moi je n'étais rien du tout et il a
été d'une gentillesse d'une camaraderie
bon il m'a choisi comme ami et il aurait
pu me traiter tout autrement
et ça je n'ai jamais oublié et pendant
les années 30 nous avons été très amis
ma femme lui avec lui clara aussi nous
avons assisté un petit peu au
déchirement entre lui elle mais je suis
resté je cause de la faim en relation
affective avec l'âge je remarque par
exemple que vous vous n'entrez pas dans
les années 30 au comité de vigilance des
intellectuels antifascistes alors que
lui en est l une des issues comment ça
se fait mais je n'ai pas été à cette
époque aussi proche du parti communiste
que lui à l'époque que vous mais vous
étiez proche de malraux à l'époque on
pouvait avoir des désaccords sur l'union
soviétique sans rompre
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y avait à
l'époque il y avait malgré tout une
communauté c'est l antifascisme nous
étions tous anti fasciste et je me
reproche dans ses mémoires d'avoir été
comme les autres obsédé par l'anti
fascisme
non pas que je jamais j'ai été si peu
que ce soit stalinien et lorsque il y a
eu d'accord entre staline et hitler j'ai
eu pour ainsi dire un sentiment de
libération de pouvoir enfin exprimer
totalement ce que je pensais du régime
soviétique ce que je n'osais pas aussi
longtemps que je me convaincs quai
que pour triompher de hitler on aurait
besoin de staline alors en ce qui
concerne malraux et le communisme en
privé il parlait avec une très grande
liberté sur le régime soviétique et il
ne tenait pas un langage stalinien s'il
avait parlé comme un stalinien ce site
était impossible mais quand ils
revenaient d'espagne et venez causer
avec nous bien on est étudiant de
l'antifascisme une fusion nous
rencontrer d'autre part dire qu'il n'a
pas fait d'influencés qui n'a pas eu une
influence sur moi je viens moi je n'ai
pas eu non plus d' influence sur lui
certainement mais après la guerre nous
nous sommes rencontrés en charge et du
directeur de son cabinet c'est ça et
puis j'ai trouvé un malraux que j'avais
quitté en 1939 qui ne voulait absolument
pas rompre avec le parti communiste
pendant une soirée en ce sens avec à 4
je les suppliais de dire qu'il rompait
avec le parti communiste il a refusé
obstinément en disant je ne peux pas
rompre avec le parti communiste du
moment que le gouvernement stupide a mis
les communistes au pouvoir
quand je les retrouver après la
libération
j'ai trouvé un malraux plus
passionnément anticommuniste moi même
sans qu'il ne m'ait jamais expliqué
pourquoi la seule explication qu'il
m'est donnée a été la phrase ils m'ont
compterait toujours on peut faire une
question d'actualité comment